what is he waiting for President Biden
has vowed to visit the site of the toxic
train derailment in Ohio quote at some
point but the White House staff says
that's news to them
are there any plans for President Biden
to visit East Palestine I don't have
anything to share on a planned visit for
the president to uh to Ohio
even Democrats are begging Joe to visit
former Ohio rep Tim Ryan said he was
shocked the president hasn't gone saying
quote this is not a hard one it's
imperative that he shows up there and
not just shed light on the cleanup but
make sure the effort is sustained mayor
Pete went but now he's moved on to other
important things like impressing Hillary
Clinton
you're dealing sometimes with the noise
machine that seems to have little to do
with your day-to-day work and a lot to
do with perceptions about your real or
perceived role in presidential politics
I would be very indecent of me to
complain of that sitting next to you
again I'm humbled to have a word like
Trailblazer used when I'm sitting next
to you and knowing all the cracks you
put in that glass ceiling for all the
challenges we're dealing with in
transportation right now this is the
best job in the federal government which
is that we're we're building the future
like literally
well Greg I didn't plan on asking this
question but when he says it's the best
job in federal government that being
Secretary of Transportation why is it
for him the best job because he's a
Trailblazer he's a Trailblazer didn't
you realize that he goes oh people say
I'm a Trailblazer but you know you're a
Trailblazer I'm just happy that he's you
know he's hanging out with a better
class of people maybe you know he's I'm
she's not the you know the mayor of
College Park Maryland but who is
no I'm also I mean you know the funny
thing is you know liberals will go to uh
Palestine but they won't go to Palestine
because it's just not cool enough you
know it's like there's something edgy
about the BDS movement but there's
nothing edgy over a flyover country or
working class families who are who are
getting screwed this is the way it's
always been the Democratic party is the
party of over-educated angry liberal
women they're not a party for families
they're not partying for working class
families that's suddenly becoming the
turf of the Republicans all right so
Geraldo I mean Joe Biden's whole
identity is tied up in this you know
personal loss connection with the worker
growing up in Pennsylvania certainly one
day is the guy he has no plans he hasn't
gone there what's even Tim Ryan is like
what's going on I'm with Tim Ryan I
can't understand why he has been so
insensitive and so stubborn about
visiting I think that with Buddha judge
uh and and now with the president United
States is an aspect of I'll show those
critics I'll go when I feel like it uh
Erica was down the past the Tim Ryan's
old District Youngstown a speech and
debate tournament with our daughter Soul
uh the people of East Palestine East
Palestine still very very worried about
their future their home values the uh
the dioxin the toxic you know
implications of what they've been
exposed to it's terrible I will say I'm
proud that our two senators Sherrod
Brown and JD Vance won the Democrat the
other Republican have proposed
legislation uh on these uh these cargo
trains uh minimum Cruise uh and
notification and communities that has
this material is passing through that's
very good legislation I like that it's
bipartisan it's a start let's get this
going and the president please Mr
President these are your constituents
you must go and visit them you know
Jesse the toxic removal of the soil
removal isn't even completed and it
won't be completed for months do you
think Joe Biden would get a warm
reception if he showed up now
I would hope he would get a warm
reception I would hope the people of
East Palestine wouldn't go there and
throw things and yell at them I I and it
would mean a lot to them after all this
to have the president come visit when
you're older you get stubborn and Joe
Biden's an old politician doesn't want
to feel bullied into doing something he
wasn't planning to do so he's going to
be asked about this and he's going to
keep ignoring it and
I don't know how long he could get away
with it it's kind of struck the American
people in their hearts this story and it
could become his Achilles heel the way
the Border was when you go to the Border
when are you going to the board yeah
again it could become one of those
things that he's dogged by and until he
does it he's going to pay a political
price for it this thing is going to go
on for quite some time oh yeah so he's
got plenty of time to do this then
there's Pete the last place you want to
go is share a stage with Hillary Clinton
you do not want to involve yourself in
the Clinton Global initiative it's it's
toxic yeah uh it is not and when you go
there and act like you're a victim and
he's complaining about bad press this
guy gets more good press than any
transportation secretary in the history
of Transportation secretaries don't go
wine and commiserate with crooked
Hillary Clinton who's always the victim
he's better than that but he has to
rehab himself because their bench is so
thin on the left that we can't afford to
have mayor Pete take any more blows it's
either him or Kamala all right
Dana Norfolk Southern is proposing
um not proposing legislation but it's
making changes specifically with respect
to that hot bearing detector the one
that heated up but didn't do the alert
that it should have done which would
would have alerted the crew to stop the
train is this their preempting any kind
of legislation or civil lawsuit what do
you think they're doing probably because
one needs maybe because it needs to be
done on the merits but also remember the
CEO is going to be in front of Congress
next week in front of a committee so he
wants to be able to say we have already
taken such measures
um so there's the company's crisis
Communications which is something to be
desired I've never seen anything like
this from a a modern presidential
group that is sometimes like really on
their game but on this one they just
keep hitting uh what is that a swing and
a miss is that what they call it it's
getting to be baseball season soon uh
remember that question of to the
president when will you go to the Border
why won't you go to the Border you've
never been to the Border why won't you
go to the Border as soon as Biden went
to the border and literally did nothing
the question stopped he himself said he
was going to go at some point so the
press secretary shouldn't be surprised
that they're like when are you going to
go and I think the people there in East
Palestine would welcome him they'd want
to know him to know this is what we're
worried about they're concerned that
they're going to be forgotten and if the
president goes and says I've talked to
everybody in the cabinet I'm going to
make sure everything we're going to make
sure somebody's here Michael Reagan will
be here and if they don't want Pete
that's fine but the other thing I'd
point out is there is an opening on the
president's populace left if he doesn't
declare soon and try to wrap this thing
up you could have somebody actually
declare and run in New Hampshire
Marianne Williamson's already declared
but RFK Jr has also said well maybe I'll
throw my hat in the ring so you wonder
what is going on there they're going oh
actually we're going to talk about that
next a little about Jill Biden okay all
right well thank you Dana I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now